caleb man congratulations you just came
off a huge win against two formidable
opponents
now not only do you have the chance at
redemption here but revenge as well
because you're going against the man who
knocked you out of this competition last
time and broke your blade our undefeated
judge ben abbott
[Music]
yeah caleb is a relatively young smith
but he's got a lot of talent he's
definitely going to be difficult to beat
nice job brother thank you how are we
feeling ben feeling pretty good ready to
go
now there's a lot at stake here
ben you're going up for your seventh
fortune fire champion title
caleb you're here to take home your
first and get a check for ten thousand
dollars now here's how it's gonna work
gentlemen
in this final round of competition you
guys are building a blade that caleb
chose
in an eight-hour straight bladesmithing
competition
you chose this
the chinese war sword oh
the 17th century chinese war sword was
used in battle starting in the zing
dynasty through 20th century
primarily used by peasant armies this
large two-handed weapon fatally slashed
and chopped through more than 3 000
japanese forces during world war ii this
deadly blade previously appeared on
season 7 of fortune fire where both
smith struggled with the weight and size
of this massive sword but in the end
once of its weapon fell victim to the
dreaded ice block
[Music]
your time starts now
i've got roughly 34 layers it's a really
really needy billet that way when i draw
it out i can cut at least four or five
pieces and i'll be well over the layer
count as soon as my billet is at welding
temperature i'm just gonna set the welds
i've got 34 layers
so i'm just gonna get four stacks at
five inches long and that'll give me
about 136 layers
and that way i can go ahead and get
welded up i've got my pierced tip my
blade is forged to shape and it's about
time for me to get ready to go into the
heat treat
there's a lot of material there that can
decide to warp or potentially crack so
pretty nervous going into this quench
caleb's now quenched
i don't actually see any warps right now
i'm feeling good and i'm feeling
confident this handle is very very big
so much harder wrap a quarter of the top
and the last quarter of the bottom and
leave the middle section shown i feel
like i've got a nice sharp blade and i
can't wait to see how mine and his
blades fare during this test
[Music]
this sword is huge i mean it's four
inches tall at the tip it's just
a big big
monster
once i know the welds on both bullets
are set i take the first bullet and
start drawing it out
my goal is to get two billets that are
20 inches long
because each billet i want to get four
pieces that i can stack up
[Music]
now that i've got this blade shaped and
profiled i've got to get this thing
quenched otherwise i will not have time
to do the rest of it
there's a warp
uh oh
i'm doing a thing i've seen
many times as a judge and i've seen it
snap so many times
but i know i cannot show up to this
testing with a works blade that has sent
people home
this could be the thing that gives me my
first loss
i'm i'm just nervous
i'll take it
this is a chinese war sword let's put a
chinese dragon on this thing i think it
looks really good
i'm trying to make this sword look as
historically accurate as i can and a lot
of the historical examples i've seen
have ito some katana handle wrap
material
there's not a lot of time left i have to
wrap as fast as i can
so far in an eight hour competition
this is the the best thing i've made
five four three
two
one bladesmiths put down your blades
this eight hour challenge is over all
right bladesmiths
two beautiful swords but now it's time
to find out how lethal they are this is
a dynamic kill test
shall we begin
holy cow
all right gents on this blue anvil
weapon when you pick it up
it's got that forward weight but being a
two-handed sword it actually is
comfortable now in terms of the edge
well pretty much demolished this
ballistics dummy overall
it will kill
caleb's blade performed really well if
my blade takes a bend when caleb's did
not
it's over for me
all right guys right off the bat i mean
it is a light
weapon to wheel
the edge is very sharp and in every cut
it was very deep
overall this weapon
it will kill
all right gentlemen it's time for the
dynamic strength test we've got bamboo
and kane in our bamboo forest over here
blue weapon is up first you both ready
let's do it
[Music]
[Music]
hey
all right so the blue anvil sword it's a
it's a heavy piece and and it's very
forward-weighted edge held up nice when
i run my finger down it there's one spot
that i can feel something but
literally have to run my fingernail down
that edge to feel it all in all
held up beautifully can't complain
uh
[Music]
[Music]
all right
as far as the edge goes no damage
whatsoever
the decorative touches are nice but what
i really like about this blade is its
functionality
all around good blade really nice and
done
[Music]
placements this has been an awesome
competition but the time has come for us
to find out if ben
you're gonna remain undefeated or if
caleb you're gonna be first one to take
down the champ and go home with the
title of fortune fire champion and get a
check for ten thousand dollars
now our judges
had quite the discussion
but they came up with a common decision
the winner of today's forge and fire
competition is
ben abbott you have done it again
congratulations
caleb you built a beautiful strong and
sharp blade but unfortunately it didn't
make the cut today and dave baker's
gonna tell you why ben's blade with that
dragon and pattern and the handle wrap
was just more impressive
absolutely now caleb
it's been an honor watching you work but
unfortunately
at this point i'm gonna have to ask you
to please step off the fourth floor
thank you then good fight that was
awesome thank you so much thank you all
good job caleb well ben
that's it man you are now 7-0 in this
forge congratulations buddy
oh my god i just won another competition
and now 7-0 this is phenomenal it's i
i'm almost kind of starting to get used
to winning this thing
among all your blades that i've ever
wielded i'd say this is the best one
thank you so much
the only issue now of course is that
every time i win i'm more and more and
more afraid of a loss
you